Muay Thai stance in under a minute.
Heel toe about one and 1/2 times
until your weights under your shoulders and hips.
Pretend to wrap a towel around your head
or be able to wipe your eyebrows.
To have your hands up and don't flare your elbows,
protect your ribs.
To maintain a solid foundation,
squeeze your glutes and your core.
This allows you to be in an active stance.
To check a kick or respond with your own at any time,
keep your weight below you.
Wanna move left,
start with your left leg.
Wanna move backwards,
start with your back leg.
To encourage good habits,
practice an offensive or defensive move
as soon as you transfer your weight.
That's my favorite way to break down the